mueve el rayo de modo que tenga como
punto final el punto b y que pase por el
punto
posteriomente completa la proposición de
la derecha ok entonces aquí tenemos un
rayo que puedo mover moviendo estos
puntos supongo
queremos que el punto final quede en el
punto b el punto final es el vértice lo
voy a poner ahí y queremos que pase por
el punto a entonces voy a hacer que este
otro punto sea justo el punto a ok
entonces ya hice lo primero que me piden
y luego tengo que completar la
proposición de la derecha esto es un
rayo o semi recta porque tiene tiene que
ningún punto extremo un punto extremo
dos puntos extremos un punto extremo
verdad un rayo tiene un punto extremo y
se prolonga indefinidamente en
en una dirección tiene un punto extremo
y se prolonga indefinidamente en esta
dirección de por acá que sería hacia
arriba a la derecha correcto vamos a
hacer otro de éstos dice arrastra el
rayo arrastra el rayo de manera que
tenga su punto de origen en el punto a y
que pase por uno de los otros puntos
negros
el rayo debe ser perpendicular a la
línea rosa a ver entonces el punto de
origen debe de estar en nada
y debo de mover el otro para que sea
perpendicular a la línea rosa aquí no es
perpendicular aquí tampoco se ve que sea
perpendicular entonces debe ser este de
acá otra vez esto es un rayo semi recta
porque tiene un punto extremo el punto e
nada y se prolonga indefinidamente en
una dirección correcto uno último va
dice usa los segmentos para conectar
todos los posibles pares de puntos a b c
y d
posteriormente completa la proposición
de la derecha guau esto se ve muy
divertido a ver va a con b luego voy a
poner a con d
voy a poner a
11 ya terminé de poner los que salen de
a
ahora vamos a poner b con c
beck dónde ya terminé los debe y sólo me
falta de conce
dice estos son segmentos de línea porque
cada uno tiene dos puntos extremos me
imagino y continúan índice
indefinidamente continúan
indefinidamente en ninguna dirección
ninguna dirección muy bien puedo
responder el problema pero no puedo leer
indefinidamente bueno comprobar
respuesta excelente